E aí
[Música]
em 2015 eu estava passando por um
processo de descobrir Negra
politicamente
É sim porque o racismo no Brasil em
continuar gente esse tipo de Façanha
Olá tudo bem graças ao movimento de
mulheres negras eu estava me desvendando
me descobrindo tardiamente Negra e
pertencente a um grupo de pessoas
dotadas de uma queza cultural que eu
precisava conhecer Na tentativa de
recuperar o tempo perdido eu passei a
buscar isso em todos os espaços
e é uma busca pessoal na verdade eu só
queria me encontrar nessa época eu vou
fazer letras de na faculdade não me
achei nos livros adotados pelo curso
é mas aquela minha buscar era tão forte
que não me conformei reclamei com
professor compartilhei medi aqui na São
com meus colegas letras
e daí a gente se juntou e fez uma
manifestação artística na semana de
letras reivindicando obras autoras
negras no curso
e a coordenadora do curso uma mulher
também Negra foi tocada pela nossa
movimentação e prometeu que dali em
diante o curso de letras daquela
instituição passaria a a votar obras de
autoras negras na bibliografia
obrigatória
há quase um ano depois eu iniciei um
curso técnico em biblioteconomia
Ah e ainda buscando Não mexe na estante
da biblioteca da Escola Técnica ali
também não havia outras línguas
bom então vamos que mulheres negras na
minha sala de aula
em uma turma de 40 alunos encontrei três
juntas deram os dez porcento um número
pequeno né mas suficiente para abalar as
estruturas da pirâmide social digo isso
porque como bem observou Angela Davis
quando uma mulher negra se movimenta
toda a estrutura da sociedade se
movimenta com ela Afinal estamos na base
então eu me movimentei em direção as
minhas três colegas que se levantaram
comigo para mudar a realidade da
biblioteca daquela escola
e ganhamos doações de livros de autoras
negras francesa da biblioteca E aí vamos
ações de incentivo à leitura das obras o
que gerou uma fila decréscimo na
biblioteca da escola
e a partir dos resultados desta ação e
depois de fazer uma pesquisa que
identificavam a escassez de obras de
autoras negras acervos das bibliotecas
públicas
e nós decidimos então criar um projeto
de incentivo à leitura de obras da
escritora negra que promove até hoje
atividades culturais a fim de contribuir
para a formação e aumento do público
leitor essas autores como objetivo
editor na notável a importância da
inclusão dessas obras nos acervos das
bibliotecas e
ou seja como for os objetivos do projeto
estão para além de incluir livros de
autoras negras nas estantes das
bibliotecas
é batalhar por isso é em primeiro lugar
uma causa que a gente considera
importante e urgente sobretudo porque
boa parte das mulheres e meninas negras
tem as bibliotecas públicas como o único
meio de acesso à leitura
é uma vez que livros no Brasil são
objetos caros
e Entretanto a intenção do projeto
também não é somente assegurar a
representatividade e leitoras negras é
também contribue para o deslocamento de
autoras negras nas margens para o centro
do universo literário
tá combatendo assim o racismo eo sexismo
ainda tão presente na nossa sociedade
eu acredito portanto que terá outras
negras não cabe somente o povo negro
e trata-se de uma tarefa obrigatória a
todos
é em suma é por ter consciência de que a
biblioteca é um espaço político de
fundamental importância social onde o
Saber está nos livros guardados de suas
estantes que o nosso projeto reivindica
mais acesso a saberes diversos começando
pela base da pirâmide social por isso a
nossa luta é prioritariamente por mais
mulheres negras nas bibliotecas e quando
eu digo Nossa estou me referindo não só
a minha July
é porque aqui vocês estão vendo só nós
duas e
É mas esse projeto é movimentado com a
força de muitas
e nós estamos com as nossas vocês traz e
as mulheres negras do agora para as do
Futuro improve de um tempo melhor para
todos quando eu tinha nove anos de idade
eu lembro que eu me sentia muito
deslocada fora do lugar eu lembro que eu
ficava horas e horas embaixo de um pé de
manga pensando sobre a vida imaginando
se existe há algo depois desta vida eu
na verdade buscava De forma inconsciente
uma resposta para a sensação de não
pertencimento que eu sentia até que eu
fui salvo por um livro isso mesmo que
você ouviu um livro me salvou do
não-lugar e o nome deste livro é o
patinho feio quem conhece essa história
sabe que na verdade o patinho feio era
um belo de um cisne mas até ele descobri
isso ele teve que passar por esse
processo do
é do que não era pertencente a sua
comunidade o estranho enfim o feio
quando ele essa história gente eu lembro
que eu me para mim foi uma revolução foi
como Ubuntu eu sou porque porque nós
somos e a partir daí eu comecei a Nutri
me a esperança de que um dia encontrar o
lugar que eu me sentisse completa cheia
preenchida assim como aconteceu com o
patinho feio e sim eu encontrei o meu
lugar e esse lugar gente é a literatura
o lugar das possibilidades da
diversidade onde o cinto o sangue correr
pelo meu corpo é o lugar que me ilumina
Mas também eu percebi que parece que
esse lugar não é para todo mundo o
acesso à literatura não é a realidade do
brasileiro
o segundo a pesquisa Retratos da leitura
do Instituto pró-livro em 2011 no Brasil
eram lidos por habitante quatro livros
por ano esse dado não teve uma mudança
agora neste ano de 2020 uma mudança
significativa essa pesquisa também
mostra que quanto maior o nível de
escolaridade mais motivado brasileiro se
sente para ler e aí é importante
pensarmos aqui a partir de algumas
questões quem no Brasil tem maior nível
de escolaridade quem no Brasil têm mais
acesso à educação a ponto de entender a
importância da leitura can e aqui é
importante trazer alguns dados para
vocês entenderem um pouco da realidade
do nosso país no Brasil setenta e cinco
porcento dos mais pobres são negros
setenta por cento dos mais ricos são
brancos dados de 2018
os dados pelo Instituto Brasileiro de
geografia e estatística IBGE mostraram
que pretos e pardos ganham em média 10
reais por hora trabalhada enquanto
brancos r$ 17 por hora trabalhada
fazendo aí um recorte entre os que têm
formação superior e se melhora um pouco
mas não equipara e aí pretos e pardos
passam a ganhar 22 reais por hora
trabalhada e brancos 32 reais em 2018
ainda pela primeira vez um Marco na
história do nosso país registrou mais de
cinquenta por cento dos matriculados nas
universidades públicas pretos e pardos
foi o marco só que por outro lado também
um dado muito importante mostrou que
mais de 61 por cento dos jovens na idade
entre 18 e 24 anos não continue sendo
médio não continuou seus estudos porque
precisa
se calhar ajudar no sustento da casa
ajudar no sustento dos seus familiares
portanto minha gente pessoas negras e
pardas têm menos acesso à educação
superior
e ganham menos São pessoas que precisam
infelizmente cuidar da sobrevivência da
urgência ser então diante desse cenário
o livro realmente objetos de luxo é o li
o livro é coisa de Elite de uma
determinada classe social que deve ter
acesso e que tem acesso e vocês devem
estar se perguntando também e afinal os
leitores quem lê está lendo o que ainda
segundo o Instituto para o livro nas
pesquisas de 2017 2007/2016 a Bíblia
outros livros religiosos e livros
didáticos são os mais lidos pelos
leitores brasileiros a os livros
didáticos porque são obrigatórios a
Bíblia e outros livros religiosos Porque
Será porque nós somos um dos países mais
religiosos do mundo e além de tempo para
abrir para Bíblia nos
o tempo para televisão Redes Sociais
música e internet portanto não somos um
país leitor de Literatura e não
frequentamos bibliotecas não Acordamos
10 horas da manhã ávidos por irmos a uma
biblioteca Oba avó biblioteca e lê e me
divertir com muitas leituras Não isso
não acontece não sejamos ingênuos mas é
importante entendermos essa realidade
para entendermos de que maneira podemos
agir sobre ela e trabalhar pela
transformação pela mudança se é que isso
é possível E também o fato de não ler
muita literatura não quer dizer que não
conhecemos alguns autores não quer dizer
que nunca vimos ou nunca ouviram ouvimos
falar de alguns autores vou apresentar
alguns autores aqui para vocês tem
certeza que vocês já ouviram falar dele
E os autores homens Euclides da Cunha
Jorge Amado Ignacio de Loyola Brandão e
as mulheres Clarice Lispector e Cecília
Meireles Lygia Fagundes Telles e agora
esses autores atenção a esses autores
Lima Barreto Joel Rufino Solano Trindade
e as autoras Maria Firmina dos Reis Ruth
Guimarães e Cidinha da Silva já ouviram
falar porque será que nunca ouvimos
falar tanto desses autores quanto
ouvimos dos outros autores dos outros
escritores é uma pergunta também
importante para o nosso processo de
reflexão
a falar de literatura então em um país
que não ler literatura parece uma perda
de tempo
é mas é a partir desse lugar que nós
resolvemos encarar uma mudança que
acreditamos ser urgente no nosso país
Pois é minha gente
e além de Literatura e um país que não
ler literatura bibliotecas em um país
que não frequenta bibliotecas nós
resolvemos e mais lá embaixo da pirâmide
social para falar de literatura de
autoras negras o grupo mais
marginalizado do nosso país que ganha os
menores salários ocupa os cargos
subalternizados e são tratados como
invisíveis
e é isso mesmo É nesse lugar que nós
resolvemos atuar porque quando falamos
devemos ler mais autoras negras muita
gente mal-intencionada pensa nossa agora
vou ter que parar de ler os autores
brancos vou ter que parar de ler as
autoras brancas Não é nada disso o nosso
convite é para ampliar O Nosso
repertório acessar um outro Imaginário
sobre o pessoas negras através da
literatura feita por essas mulheres não
limitar as nossas perspectivas
literárias a uma determinada visão isso
é empobrecer as nossas possibilidades
sejamos como acontece na natureza quanto
mais um solo é diverso rico em
nutrientes mas forte e eficiente ele é
na nossa sociedade não é diferente ela
também é diversa diversa de Cultura
pensamento pessoas e quanto mais a gente
se expõe
a adversidade mais aptos nos tornamos a
viver em sociedade esse é o nosso
convite que a gente amplie os nossos O
Nosso repertório nós concordamos com
grande Antônio Cândido quando defendeu o
direito Universal à Literatura e com a
escritora Conceição Evaristo quando diz
se não Lemos todos os passos criativos'
de uma nação estamos lendo uma nação em
pedaços Estamos lendo uma nação
incompleta portanto se não Lemos essas
autoras estamos ignorando a existência
de margens 54 por cento da população
brasileira nós queremos esses livros sim
na cesta básica do brasileiro junto ali
com arroz e com feijão nenhum nem outro
os dois porque a fome no Brasil não está
somente
e no estômago nós vivemos uma
precarização na nossa formação cognitiva
e isso pode ser mudado com a literatura
EA literatura de autoras negras por mais
autoras negras das bibliotecas por mais
autoras negras no Nosso repertório
urgente